bernard tapie 39 ans propriétaire d'un
groupe de 42 entreprises et 8000
salariés chiffre d'affaires annuel 5
milliards de francs lourd son ambition
devenir dans quelques années l'un des
tout premiers patrons de france mais moi
j'assume je suis un vrai capitaliste qui
vit comme un capitaliste moi j'ai le
droit au profit je me le donne ce droit
ça veut dire que j'ai le droit d'avoir
un jet je l' ai gagnée
volontiers provocateur patron mais aussi
aux hommes de médias bernard tapie s'est
spécialisé dans le sauvetage des
entreprises en difficulté pu la créer
s'approfondit plus lui il s'enrichit
[Musique]
venir
la guerre ou la crise d'où ce sont des
événements qui permettent une
redistribution des cartes dont seule
seconde un profil adapté aux problèmes
posés vont profiter c'est à dire qui a
pas vraiment une crise il ya des bons et
des mauvais c'est pas ça c'est qu'il ya
eu ni d'adaptation un certain nombre de
gens à faire face aux questions qu'ils
se posent d'un footballeur peut pas être
mis en cause si vous le mettez sur une
bicyclette c'est pas que c'est plus dur
au moins dur c'est que c'est pas le même
genre de sport
testud entreprise de pesage basée dans
une ville moyenne du nord béthune
23 mars 1983 comme 25 mille entreprises
françaises chaque année testud fait
faillite et dépose son bilan
des centaines de salariés sont menacés
de chômage
gorge profonde nous l'avons appelé gorge
profonde par allusion à l'informateur
anonyme des deux journalistes du
washington post pendant la sphère du
watergate et comme eux nous
rencontrerons gorge profonde la nuit ici
et là dans paris gorge profonde c'est le
mélange de plusieurs fonctionnaires des
administrations économiques que nous
avons rencontrés mais qui ont tenu à
garder l'anonymat
or le diagnostic de gorge profonde et
sans appel pour lui plus de la moitié
des patrons français ne sont pas à la
hauteur
l'économie aussi est un roman
pour vous parler de la vie et de la mort
des entreprises nous avons choisi de
voir raconter une histoire ce sera donc
celle de testut pourquoi testud parce
que sa chute montre bien comment une
entreprise peut mourir de ses propres
erreurs en mars 1983 testud en faillite
et reprise par bernard tapie son projet
faire un peu de temps d'une entreprise
qui perd une entreprise qui gagne selon
lui dans le monde des entreprises comme
dans la vie il ya des méthodes qui
permettent de réussir de ses méthodes on
pense pas à ce qu'on voudra mais d'abord
l'histoire
prenons les choses par le début nous
sommes en janvier 1983 à ce moment là
vous avez déjà racheté terraillon et
vous vous intéressez à testud et bien
sûr parce qu'entre 80 déjà et 83 on a
racheté près de quatre boîtes l'a
racheté be là en italie on a racheté bac
qui fait en espagne jupiter et c'est bon
alors on est dans une perspective de
développement intensif dans le secteur
du pesage alors testud pour nous c'est
la première société française c'est pas
loin d'être la première européenne à
l'époque c'est 350 millions de chiffre
d'affaires près de 2000 personnes et
c'est surtout une technologie qui couvre
à peu près l'ensemble des besoins du
pesage ça va du pèse personne jusqu'au
facebook en comprenant des balances
poids prix et etc donc c'est une société
qui nous intéresse
béthune vingt-huit mille habitants à 40
km de lille
testud à béthune c'est d'abord une
manufacture d'horlogerie qui devient
avec les années le numéro un du pesage
en france et pourtant à partir de 1975
les premiers signes de déclin
apparaissent
à la fin de 1982 la situation devient
préoccupante
le premier à alerter c'est le député
maire socialiste de béthune jacques
mellick
monsieur le maire à l'origine comment
avez vous appris la difficulté de la
société testud délégués syndicaux m'ont
alerté plusieurs mois avant
l'officialisation des difficultés yann
aux sanctions que les stocks augmentent
et cela n'est pas trompeur cela veut
dire simplement que si on produit qu'on
ne vend pas c'est qu'on est plus
concurrentiel c'est à ce moment là qu'on
est allé le voir mellick en lui disant
bon la situation est en train de se
dégrader mais qu'est ce qui concrètement
ça veut dire quoi leurs idées y en avait
on se rendait compte qu'il y avait des
pères qui avait un chiffre d'affaires
qui a baissé on peut dire que les points
faibles étaient presque présent partout
comme c'est pratiquement toujours le cas
quand ça va pas bien il y avait un
bureau d'études qui fonctionnait plus
bien il y avait un service technique qui
était pas assuré le label de qualité
n'existait pas l'informatique
fonctionner à l'envers c'est à dire
qu'elles constataient des insuffisances
mais un an après il n'y avait pas de
d'analytique quotidienne ou hebdomadaire
on peut dire qu'il y avait des
positionnements de produits qui se
concurrençaient ça veut dire que une
société à béthune faisais ce que la
société à lui on faisait ce que la
société à ivry faisaient tout en se
faisant concurrence à eux mêmes bon tout
peut pas dire tel ou tel point vous
savez quand quand un pilote est mauvais
il passe mal c'est vitesse il freine au
mauvais moment il tourne pas le bon
volant ils débrayent pas quand il faut
il regarde pas s'il ya de l'huile il met
pas les sens il tombe en panne d'eau
dire c'est tout en france quand une
entreprise des difficultés elles se
tournent généralement vers l'état et
l'état c'est le ciri comité
interministériel de restructuration
industrielle
une sorte d'infirmerie pour les
entreprises malades placés sous la
tutelle du ministère des finances qui
distribue les crédits comme d'autres des
médicaments et l'aller les conclusions
étaient dramatiques pour l'entreprise
c'était pratiquement la fin de
l'entreprise on ne donnait rien plus
dans toi suppression de la totalité des
emplois suppression de tous les emplois
et aussi tous les emplois il n'y avait
vraiment pas d'avenir lorsque je me
souviens avoir rencontré les
responsables dudit syrie à l'hôtel
matignon je vais en demande au premier
ministre d'organiser cette cette table
ronde je suis sorti de cette rencontre
totalement catastrophe et pas de
perspective
quand on lui parle les entreprises en
difficulté
quand je profonde pour un ton désabusé
aux périodes de stagnation et chômage
tout licenciement et
syndicats s'y opposent de toutes leurs
forces l'inspection du travail les
reflux devant cette situation certains
patrons viennent à utiliser le dépôt de
bilan comme un moyen de gestion mais
cette dramatisation joue contre en
entreprises et salariés ont peur les
créanciers s'affolent les banquiers
refusent les crédits l'entreprise est
ballotté dans la tempête est parfois
mise en pièces on appelle le ciri aux
secours la politique s'en mêle tel
députés intervient tel ministre fait
pression la logique sociale et
économique s'efface alors devant la
bataille des groupes de pression et
bientôt le problème de gestion se
transforme en ouest et en économique
mais alors le ciri s'est contenté de
vous proposer cette solution de quasi
disparition ou bien ce qu'il a fait
d'autres propositions agneaux stick mais
aussi une possibilité de salut et la
planche de salut c'était bernard tapie
est alors vers un tapis c'est la douche
froide pour le maire de béthune à ce
moment-là berlin tapis c'est un peu
manufrance est ce que ça serait pas
lagache millau des années 80 les daltons
sur une entreprise en difficulté l'aigle
qui arrive pour prendre les restes alors
l'iphone et itunes c'était de savoir
est-ce que c'est simplement un financier
ou est-ce que c'est aussi à l'industriel
je me suis donc présenté à ses bureaux
l'ambiance a été bonne mais
immédiatement ambiance assez assez
sombre pas beaucoup de lumière reçue par
lui et trois de ses collaborateurs
j'avais l'impression que le verdict
était déjà tombée que c'était lorsqu'il
me l'a dit je ne peux garder que 120
personnes je pense ceci je transfère
cette activité à annemasse je voyais que
l'on dépouille et béthune et cela et est
conforme à l'image que je ne faisais de
tapis c'est à dire un financier avant
tout n'ayant pas d'objectifs industriels
trois bleus si notre plan a été refusée
par le député maire local c'est parce
que parmi les candidatures une s'était
fait connaître en faisant croire que
toute la structure pouvait se faire à
partir de l'étude c'est bien logique que
lui et tant qu'à béthune alors que cette
affaire elle est présente partout où
elle est présente à lyon elle est
présente dans d'autres coins de la
france il préférait un plan qui favorise
incontestablement la la structure locale
c'est là qu'ils maintenaient tous les
emplois à béthune alors on garde est non
seulement tout à béthune mais on a fait
croire au député-maire socialiste que on
fermait tout ailleurs et que et on
allait se retrouver avec une superbe
structure opérationnelle à béthune oui
j'ai pris contact avec une autre
entreprise notre société spécialisée
dans le pesage et dans les automatismes
en l'occurrence la société north qui m'a
dur est immédiatement déclaré être
intéressé par tout parti
de cet ensemble destiné trévoux et
notamment par le site d'habitude j'ai
donc poursuivi avec des responsables de
la société mort car c'était pour moi le
moyen à la fois d'avoir une carte de
rechange si tapie me claquer dans les
mains ou et aussi d'avoir une carte pour
peser si je puis vous voyez ce terme sur
bernard tapie dans le cadre des
négociations puisque j'avais bloqué
toute l'opération démarre tapis auprès
de près des pouvoirs publics
mais tapie pendant ce temps ne désarment
pas le 20 mars il envoie à béthune où
son homme de confiance gilbert bretton
un ancien de thomson afin de juger si le
malade mérite à ses yeux d'être sauvés
alors qu'elle était la conclusion
très simple partie jouable avec des
difficultés certes mais que l'on a
l'habitude de traiter ces d'autres
métiers j'ai donc téléphoné dans leurs
casiers à bernard tapie en lui indiquant
que c'était tout à fait dans nos cordes
en
la majeur là on a racheté les actions au
moment où on a décidé que cette affaire
nous vous êtes en vie et que on se
sentait capable de l'art l'ordre de
l'agresser c'était un très bon coup de
la part de berlin mais arrêtez un peu
coincé j'étais un peu passé il ne
fallait pas que je continue à être
encerclée j'ai donc tenté une sortie
avec le groupe mort ce qui m'a présenté
devant le syli a un dossier de reprise
du groupe testud trévoux j'ai la lettre
encore aider ce dossier qui était
présenté aussi et partir de ce moment là
la presse a intéressé par ce qui se
passait m'a contacté et me demander des
informations je n'ai pas manqué de lui
de les informations disons que tu as pu
organiser une petite fuite pape a
organisé la fuite mais j'ai donné cette
information que auquel les gens ne
savaient avait droit
et notamment que rien n'était joué
en effet rien n'est joué dès le
lendemain incapable de faire face à ses
dettes testud dépose son bilan
l'entreprise se passe donc sous le
contrôle du tribunal de commerce qui
désigne un administrateur provisoire m
gourdin nouvel actionnaire majoritaire
bernard tapie est bien placé pour gagner
la partie mais la loi est formelle ce
sera à l'administrateur provisoire et à
lui seul de décider qui deviendra le
patron de testut le syndic doit d'abord
dans un premier temps conformant à le
voir prendre immédiatement des mesures
conservatoires qui s'appelle les a fait
taire les estimations d utilisation
l'inventaire des stocks disant go etc
etc prendre des mesures à l'égard du
pool bancaire pour continuer à obtenir
les concours l'ancien bull bancaire
c'est évident on a besoin
par ailleurs nous avons appris qu'en
entre le dépôt de bilan et le jeu qu'on
judiciaire le groupe d'appui et est
devenu le principal actionnaire de cette
c'est ce qui va racheter des actions
d'ailleurs acheté les propos cher bien
sûr mais valait d'ailleurs à cette
époque vraiment pas très cher
tapie a présenté un pré plan de
restructuration de l'entreprise tu
passais il vous en tiendra probablement
payeur qui passait notamment par des
réductions d'effectifs importantes
et qui maintenait quand même la cohésion
du groupe et qui laissent penser qu' à
terme il doit y avoir une solution
d'avenir pour cette entreprise
parallèlement rien groupes d'importance
nationale français qui a proposé de
reprendre une partie de la sphère soit
l' usine de lyon soit les usines de
béthune ou choix mais cette solution
selon moi avec comme inconvénient un
d'arriver progressivement à démonter le
monde l'entreprise ce que ni moi ni
l'actionnaire majoritaire ni tribunal
qui quand même le contrôleur c'est de
faire ni les syndicats ne voulaient
la faire testud évolue donc vers son
dénouement résumons à ce stade de
l'histoire berlin tapie est devenu
l'actionnaire majoritaire du groupe
testud oui mais le bilan est déposée le
tribunal de commerce reste donc seul
maître de la décision finale or le plan
de redressement de tapis qui maintient
l'unité de la société obtient la
préférence du tribunal de commerce reste
pourtant la question du coût social de
la reprise
car jacques mellick le député-maire de
béthune campe lui sur ses positions
reprise oui mais à condition de
maintenir le plus d'emplois possible
habitudes il faut donc négocier
alors il a beaucoup insisté pour vous
oui téléphone au point le recteur
téléphone auprès de ma femme je fais
choo savoir que je n'étais pas
disponible j'étais absent j'étais à
l'extérieur il m'a donc écrit le 2 avril
et pour la petite histoire je vais vous
lire quelques lignes je me permets de
vous écrire puisque je ne peux malgré de
nombreuses tentatives vous joindre
téléphoniquement et depuis notre
dernière entrevue au cours de laquelle
je vous ai proposé concerne alité de
béthune j'ai appris que vous faisiez
savoir à tous les niveaux que vous étiez
résolument opposés et que vous vivant je
ne pouvais jamais mettre les pieds avec
une voix dans le vieux nice 1 1 je lui
avais dit que sur son plan sur ce projet
cela était inacceptable et que je ne le
tolérerai pas tant que je serai maire de
béthune donc il m'a écrit pour me faire
un certain nombre de propositions et
notamment pour me démolir la société
morses dans laquelle dans cette ville
qu'il me dit contrairement aux
informations
elle est actuellement contrôlé
majoritairement par une société
financière étrangère qu'est ce que cela
pouvait me faire moi je suis un homme
libre ouvert dans un environnement
international je tiens compte d'égalité
ce une entreprise étrangère était
susceptible de rapporter un produit
industriel ici habitude de me maintenir
le maximum d'emplois je suis preneur
donc c'est pas du tout ce type
d'arguments qui pouvait me convaincre et
c'est à partir de ce moment là qu'il m'a
fait savoir qu'il était disposé à
revoir son plan donc dans cette lettre
donc à partir de ce moment là la
négociation
pouvait s'ouvrir nous relation avec le
député maire sur le début je ne les ai
considéré que comme anecdotique c'était
pas ça l'essentiel pour nous l'essentiel
c'était de mettre au point un plan qui
marche dans son économie et qui soit
acceptée sur le plan social et ça ça a
été fait alors après par contre c'est
vrai qu'on peut pas travailler dans un
environnement politique pollué pervers
il était donc nécessaire de renégocier
un peu avec le député-maire irina
gestion de blocage un certain nombre
n'était pas bloquée puisqu'il n'avait
pas le pouvoir et les interventions
qu'il a pu faire auprès des pouvoirs
publics ou auprès des élus locaux
n'avaient pas d'incidence vous savez on
est encore dans le cadre d'une stratégie
juridique précise qui fait que à partir
du moment où on avait les actions à
partir devant le tribunal de commerce
acceptait appartements les syndicats
avaient accepté le plan le reste ça
devenait de la mondanité mais de la
mondanité indispensable il faut être
bien avec tout le monde
le 14 avril à 16 heures à la mairie de
béthune c'est la négociation dans cette
école les compositions les propositions
c'était bien entendu des licenciements
mais un maintien un maintien au niveau
de 300 emplois dans le groupe testud dit
assis ici habitudes c'était certains
départements supprimés ici habitude mais
par contre la constitution de toute la
logistique au niveau de la gestion de
l'entreprise it et donc des emplois
tertiaires emploie 2 avec un ca se
serait proposé au début de la réunion
c'est ce que j'ai proposé alors notre
souci ça a été de chercher en commun as
l'occasion de cette réunion là d'abord
par une meilleure connaissance des deux
hommes parce qu'il fallait qu'ils
apprennent à vivre un peu malin avec
l'autre ça a été de voir ce qu'on
pouvait projeter dans l'avenir comme
installation de futures unités de
production pour pouvoir donner un job
futur à ceux qui ont été licenciés c'est
à dire nous avons un peut préfigurer ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans la
restructuration au niveau de la cité au
niveau des charbonnages nous avons tous
les deux dans le domaine certainement
plus plus réduit essayez de
l'expérimenté et je peux dire qu'au bout
d'un an puisque nous pratiquement nous
sommes un an de cette date du 14 avril
les accords ont été respectés de part et
d'autre avec des ajustements mais qu'est
ce que vous avez fait ce genre là pour
convaincre gerber le dire à la limite
non il faut à un moment donné lorsque
vous avez la certitude que sur le plan
économique c'est bien vous avez résolu
que les problèmes rationnelle les
problèmes objectif et puis après il faut
prendre en compte tous les éléments
irrationnelle qui sont les mêmes pour
monsieur lui que pour moi c'était quoi y
reprennent c'est à dire faire adhérer
les gens c'est pas le tout d'avoir le
bon sens pour soi être pensé qu'on a
tout trouvé il faut aussi que les gens
adhèrent à cette idée mais celui qui
s'est retrouvé devant les travailleurs
les 400 et 3 79 personnes de tester kick
ass c'est jacques mellick c'est bien que
là il ya eu une décision est une
décision qui a été prise par le juge
commissaire en fait donc par le tribunal
d'accepter le plan de restructuration
unitaire du
du groupe tapie un dimanche d'avril
d'avenue triade landes au siège du
groupe tapie ordre du jour le
redressement de testut
quand la première chose à faire c'est de
poser un diagnostic produit par produit
autrement dit on va voir comment chaque
produit situe dans son marché global
partir de laquelle l unité de production
qui est la mieux équipée pour faire face
aux besoins de production quelle est
celle qui est la plus en avance qu'elle
est celle qui est la plus en retard on
va donner une unité avec une
caractéristique spécifique produit par
produit un réseau de distribution et
pourquoi pas une unité de centralisation
qui sera pas forcément paris
paris n'a pas de raison d'être à la
limite je crois que c'est indécent qu'on
peut le plus rapidement sur le plan de
l'emploi à rendre déflationniste d'abord
parce que la reconversion sont plus
simples et ensuite parce qu'il me semble
que ils sont très loin d'une idée
nous arrêtons ici l'histoire de texture
un an après où en sommes-nous tous les
problèmes n'ont pas encore été réglés un
certain nombre de travailleurs ont perdu
leur emploi et tous n'ont pas encore été
reclassés l'entreprise est toujours sous
contrôle judiciaire et il faudra
attendre plusieurs mois avant que l'on
retrouve sa totale indépendance pourtant
les faits sont là aujourd'hui testud
gagne de l'argent au moment du dépôt de
bilan l'entreprise perdait environ 1
milliard de centimes par mois un an
après elle gagne 500 millions de
centimes par mois alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé bah qu'est ce qui s'est
passé quand une société perd 10 millions
de francs nouveau ou un milliard de
centimes par mois en l'occurrence c'est
parce qu'elles fabriquaient cher des
produits pas très fiable avec une
méthode de gestion dépassé comment on
fait pour que cette société qui perdait
1 milliard de centimes gagnent entre 4
et 5 millions de francs nouveau dans
quatre ou cinq cents millions de
centimes c'est tout simplement en
évitant les miracles car il n'existe pas
mais en fabriquant des produits pas
chers dans les fabricants fiable et en
gérant la boîte avec une méthodologie
très performante une question de méthode
c'est uniquement une question d'hommes
et de méthode vous devez être dans un
système qui vous admettent que vous
puissiez vous trompez et c'est la
collectivité qui empêche que votre
erreur individuelle et des conséquences
négatives sur le plan collectif et ce
droit à l'erreur il est tellement
valable que vous devez en même temps ne
penser qu'au récompense lorsque la l2
l'objectif est atteint et d'éliminer
toutes les systèmes de sanctions 47
chances du tout la sanction allait nulle
elle est inutile lorsque vous promettez
un coup de pied dans le derrière à
quelqu'un s'y fait une erreur vous
donner envie aux autres de se protéger
le derrière par un oreiller et vous leur
donnez pas envie de ne pas faire
l'erreur toutes les sociétés dont les
avancées sociales sont les plus grandes
sont comme par hasard les plus
performantes ce qui veut dire que la
première forme d'améliorations de
production d'une entreprise c'est
l'amélioration de la relation sociale je
vous donne un exemple
je prends un gars normalement constitué
nous tous et je le mets dans la cour en
le priant ou en l'invitant à courir
après un ballon vous allez voir un peu
au bout de deux minutes ce qu'il va
faire il va vous ramener le ballon en
vous disant ou doute est ok ou bien
vraiment ce jeu ne m'intéresse pas et
c'est vrai que geste réellement courir
après un ballon n'a aucun intérêt
par contre si je mets onze personnes
d'un côté 11 de l'autre un monsieur tout
en noir des spectateurs autour que
j'inscris une règle que j'inscris mme un
objectif que je donne une ambition que
je crée un moteur affectif sentimentale
passionnel je fais de ce geste idiot un
match de football et ce match de
football non seulement ils intéressent
les 22 acteurs c'était la moindre des
choses mais en plus trente mille
personnes qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
geste qu'ils sont prêts à se battre avec
leurs voisins si l'équipe qu'ils ont
choisie ne marque pas vu la seconde
question qu'on se pose c'est le numéro 1
de mon entreprise celui qui nous
dirigent est ce qu'il incarne est ce
qu'il véhicule est ce qu'ils les
créateurs de symboles qui correspondent
à mon avis personnel autrement dit qui
s'assemble se ressemble
est ce que j'ai envie de ressembler à
l'image de celui qui nous anime et de
celui qui nous dirigent si la réponse
est oui on a de grandes chances
effectivement d'être mobilisateur dans
son entreprise car on crée des mythes
ont créé des messages on crée des images
l'étrange pension devait résumer
l'ensemble du problème tel qu'il se pose
on pourrait dire s'il y a un secret et
il y en a
c'est d'admettre qu'aujourd'hui pour
répondre aux exigences de cette crise il
faut des qualités tellement innombrables
et parfois même tellement
contradictoires qu'un seul être homo ne
peut pas les avoir tous fois être âgés
car il faut de l'expérience bien sûr il
faut aussi à john car il faut être
dynamique entreprenant fouette encore
plein de vie faut être prudent faut être
pessimiste parce que les choses sont
qu'elles sont et ça se passe pas
toujours bien mais par contre il faut
être optimiste faut être ambitieux faut
être créateur faut être imaginatif
quel est l'homme qui peut être vieux
jeunes ambitieux timorais ça n'existe
pas alors le vrai secret
entoure on nous des gens qui ont les
qualités que nous n'avons pas c'est la
complémentarité des compétences qui
assurera le succès et à partir de là on
peut même pratiquement dire est ce qu'un
chef d'entreprise qui aujourd'hui peut
réussir doit être obligatoirement un
homme brillant je réponds non il peut ne
rien savoir faire mais à une condition
c'est qu'il s'entoure des gens qui eux
sa fin
[Musique]